大家好,我是Jim,這裡是 AI Notebook
這集是我們新系列的第一集,叫簡史系列
每一集用一條線,把一段歷史從頭走一遍
第一集,我們走人工智慧的70年,1955年
四個美國科學家寫了一份研究申請書
說只要給他們10個人,兩個月
就能再讓機器有智慧這件事上往前走一大步
那個夏天,過去的70年也過去了
這70年裡,大家好幾次都說機器快要會思考了
然後又好幾次卡住
這一集只問一個問題,每一次卡住的到底是什麼
我先把答案放在前面,每一次卡住
都是因為我們想親手把智慧寫給機器
每一次往前
都是因為我們讓他自己從例子裡學
難的不是把智慧寫進機器
是讓他自己學出來
這條線分三步走
先看為什麼智慧寫不完
再看讓機器自己學
為什麼等了二十幾年
最後看他真的學起來以後
現在又卡在哪裡
中間有一部圍棋
人類下出來的機會大約只有萬分之一
我們留到後面
故事要從更早的一張紙開始
1950年
英國數學家Alan Turing
在一本哲學期刊上發表了一篇論文
論文的第一句話是
我想來討論一個問題
機器會思考嗎
他接著說
這個問題很難直接回答
因為思考這兩個字
每個人的定義都不一樣
所以他換了一個問法
做成一個遊戲
叫Imitation Game
中文叫模仿遊戲
後來大家叫他圖靈測試
遊戲是這樣玩的
一個人坐在房間裡
只能用打字
跟兩個看不見的對象聊天
一個是人
一個是機器
聊了一陣子以後
他要猜哪一個是機器
如果他常常猜錯
Turing說
我們就很難再堅持
機器不會思考
你會發現
這篇Turing沒有回答機器會不會思考
他把問題換成一個可以測的東西
他還預測
大約50年後
機器就能把這個遊戲玩得相當好
這一集的70年
某種程度上
都在回答這張紙上的那個問題
這篇論文最常被引用的是那個遊戲
可是在論文最後一節
Turing寫了一段很少人記得的話
他說
與其寫一個程式去模仿大人的腦袋
為什麼不寫一個模仿小孩的
然後去教他
你想一下一個小孩是怎麼學說話的
沒有人先給他一本文法書
叫他背首主詞和動詞
再開口
他是聽了成千上萬句話
說錯了
被大人糾正
慢慢自己就會了
規則不是別人寫給他的
是他從例子裡自己長出來的
這個畫面我們整集會一直回來用
就叫他學說話的小孩
所以Turing在1950年
就把兩條路都擺出來了
一條是把大人的智慧
一條一條寫下來交給機器
另一條是做一個會學的小孩
讓他自己從例子裡學
他只提出了這個想法
沒有說該怎麼做
接下來的70年
人類幾乎先把前面那條路
從頭走到底
才繞回後面這一條
Turing提出問題
五年後,美國有四個科學家
John McCarthy, Marvin Minsky, Nathaniel Rochester 和 Claude Shannon
寫了一份研究申請書
他們想在隔年夏天把一群人找到 Dartmouth 學院一起做研究
就在這份申請書裡出現了 Artificial Intelligence 這個名字
中文叫人工智慧
申請書裡有一句話把他們的信心寫得很清楚
他們認為學習和智慧的每一個方面
原則上都能描述得非常精確
精確到可以做一臺機器去模仿它
他們申請的規模是十個人
兩個月
1956年那個夏天
真的有一群人來了
有兩位研究者帶來一個程式
叫Logic Theorist
他把一本數學經典裡
前面幾十條定理
正出了一大半
有一條的正法比原書還短
下棋 證明 揭秘
這些我們覺得最需要智慧的事
好像都能一步一步寫成規則
這條路我們就叫他寫說明書
把智慧寫成一本說明書
極其照著做
那時候的人很自然地相信
只要說明書寫得夠厚
智慧就會出現
就在大家忙著寫說明書的時候
另一條路也有人在走
1958年
心理學家Frank Rosenblatt
做出了一臺機器
叫Perceptron
中文叫感知器
他的想法來自腦袋裡的神經細胞
一個神經細胞會收到很多訊號
每個訊號有輕有重
加起來超過一個門檻
它就發出訊號
感知器照這個樣子做
前面是一排感光的小眼睛
每隻眼睛接一個可以轉的旋鈕
旋鈕決定
這隻眼睛的話算多重
你給它看一張圖
它猜一個答案
猜錯了
就把旋鈕轉一點點
沒有人告訴它規則
他是從一張一張的例子裡
自己把旋鈕轉到對的位置
這就是Turing說的那個小孩
第一次有了身體
美國海軍資助了這個研究
還辦了一場記者會
紐約時報的報道說
海軍期待這臺電腦的雛形
將來能走路
說話
看
寫字
複製自己
還能意識到自己的存在
一臺只能分辨簡單圖形的機器
被寫成這個樣子
你大概猜得到
後面會發生什麼事
1960年代
是人工智慧的第一個春天
研究經費很多
每個人都很樂觀
而這些樂觀後來都留下了白紙黑紙
1965年 Herbert Simon 寫道
20年之內 機器將能做任何人能做的工作
Minsky 後來也在雜誌上說
幾年之內就會有一臺跟一般人一樣聰明的機器
說這些話的不是在路邊吹牛的人
是這個領域最頂尖的科學家
他們為什麼這麼有把握
因為在小世界裡事情真的很順
證明定理 解帶出應用體
或者在一張只有幾塊積木的桌面上
照著一句英文指令
把積木疊起來 機器都做得到
一個小世界做得到
看起來只要把世界放大就好
我們後面會一直用季節來講這段歷史
春天的時候所有人都在往前衝
可是春天說出口的話
都會被冬天拿出來一堆帳
感知器那條路
先碰到了牆
1969年
Minsky 跟 Seymour Pepper 出了一本書
書名就叫 Perceptrons 感知器
書裡用數學證明只有一層的感知器
有些非常簡單的事
怎麼學都學不會
最有名的一個例子
可以想成兩個開關和一盞燈
規則是兩個開關剛好只開一個燈才亮
兩個都開或兩個都關
燈都不亮
這件事小孩一看就懂
可是一層的感知器
做的事情就像拿一塊紙質的木板
把會亮的情況和不會亮的情況隔開
你把這四種情況擺在桌上
會發現那塊木板怎麼放
都隔不乾淨
大家知道多疊幾層也許就能學會
可是當時沒有人知道
多層的要怎麼訓練
這本書出來以後
大家對這條路的熱情很快樂地下來
研究經費轉向寫規則的那一邊
1971年
Rosenblatt再一次划船意外地過世
那天剛好是他的生日
會學的小孩那條路
幾乎沒有人走了
寫規則的那一邊
也沒有好到哪裡去
1973年
科學研究委員會請數學家James Lighthill評估人工智慧的研究
他的報告裡有一句話
大意是這個領域到目前為止沒有任何一部分
產生當初承諾的那種重大影響
問題出在哪裡
他點名了一件事叫combinatorial explosion
中文叫組合爆炸
他的意思是在積木桌上
可能的走法沒有幾種
集氣一個一個試就好
可是世界一放大
每多走一步可能性就成好幾倍
很快多到任何電腦都試不完
說明書也是這樣
你每寫一條規則就冒出三個例外
每個例外又要再寫三條
報告出來以後
英國大部分大學的人工智慧研究經費都被停掉
美國的國防研究經費也收緊了
這段時間後來被叫做人工智慧的冬天
春天說出口的話
第一次被拿出來對賬
冬天過了
1980年代春天又回來了
這次換了一個比較務實的說法
既然整個世界太大
那就只做一個小領域
而且找真正的專家來寫規則
這種東西叫Expert System
中文叫專家系統
它的做法是
寫成式的人去訪問醫生或技術人員
把他們腦袋裡的判斷一條一條寫成如果怎樣就怎樣
例如史丹佛大學的MYCIN
專門判斷血液感染該用哪一種抗生素
另一個叫XCOM
是一家電腦公司用來幫客戶配電腦零件的
據說每年幫公司省下不少錢
這一次說明書不再想寫整個世界
只寫一個專家的一小塊
效果好到很多大公司紛紛成立人工智慧部門
還出現了專門跑這種城市的電腦
日本也在1981年
開始一個國家級的十年計劃
想做出新一代會推理的電腦
第二個春天比第一個更熱
因為這一次真的有錢在流動
可是這座說明書的塔
蓋得越高問題越明顯
最先碰到的問題是專家講不出來
你去問一個看了很多年病的醫生
他為什麼覺得這個病人不對勁
他常常只能說
看起來就是怪怪的
那個怪怪的寫不成規則
再來是規則打架
規則寫到幾千條
新加一條
就可能跟舊的某一條互相矛盾
沒有人記得全部
最麻煩的是
專家系統很脆
只要碰到說明書裡沒寫的情況
他不會說我不知道
他會很有把握的給一個錯的答案
維護這些規則的成本越來越高
1987年
專門跑這類城市的電腦
市場在一年之內垮掉
日本那個十年計劃到期的時候
也沒有達到當初的目標
其實早在1984年
就有兩位資深研究者
在年會上公開警告
冬天要回來了
人工智慧的冬天這個說法
就是在那時候開始流行的
第二個冬天比第一個更冷
很多研究者寫計劃的時候
乾脆不提人工智慧這幾個字
我們是不是從一開始就把難跟簡單搞反了
1988年
機器人學家Hans Morag在書裡寫了一個觀察
後來被叫做Moravix Paradox
中文叫莫拉維克貝倫
他的意思是
讓電腦做質疑測驗下跳棋
做到大人的水準
相對容易
可是要讓他擁有一歲小孩的看跟走
很難甚至做不到
你想一下你一眼就認得出一隻貓
不管他是趴著跳著
還是隻從沙發後面露出一條尾巴
可是你能不能把怎麼認出貓
寫成一本說明書
你試了就會發現
寫不出來
你知道
可是你說不出來
這就是寫規則那條路
真正卡住的地方
智慧裡面最大的一塊不是下棋
證明這種我們說得出來的東西
是看聽走路這種
我們自己也說不出來的東西
說不出來就寫不成規則
說得出來的那一塊
寫規則的路其實走得很遠
1997年
IBM的電腦Deep Blue
在紐約跟世界西洋棋冠軍Gary Kasparov
下了六盤最後贏了
這是電腦第一次
在正式比賽的條件下
贏過當時的世界冠軍
Deep Blue是怎麼贏的
他不是比較懂棋
再用人寫好的評分規則
判斷哪個局面比較好
這是說明書加上力氣
把一個規則清楚的小世界一路算到底
這場勝利上了全世界的新聞
很多人以為機器終於會思考了
可是我們用Morrigan畫回頭看
激揚棋
剛好是那個簡單一邊
棋盤就那麼大
規則寫得完
輸贏很清楚
而在同一個年代
你拿一張普通的照片給電腦
要他認出裡面有沒有一隻貓
他還是非常吃力
我們先停一下
把第一部分收起來
這部分的問題是
能不能把智慧一條一條寫給機器
答案是
寫得了一部分
寫不完
說得出來的那一塊
像下棋證明定理
寫規則的路走得很遠
甚至贏了世界冠軍
可是說不出來的那一塊
像認出一隻貓
聽懂一句話
寫不成說明書
專家講不出自己的直覺
規則越寫越多
互相打架
碰到沒寫到的情況
就很有把握的出錯
兩個冬天
卡住的都是同一件事
沒跟上的話
記住這一句
智慧裡最大的一塊
是我們自己也說不出來的
最後那一節嘛
如果寫不出來
就只剩另一條路
我們不寫了
讓機器像學說話的小孩一樣
自己從例子裡學
這條路Rosenblatt走過
被一本書擋了下來
它又重新被剪起來
得先解決那塊木板
隔不開的問題
我們要讓機器自己學
得先講清楚
學到底是怎麼一回事
這種會學的機器
今天叫Neural Network
中文叫神經網絡
它就是很多個感知器
一層接一層疊起來
每一條連接上
都有一個旋鈕
一個網絡可以有
成千上萬個旋鈕
學習的過程只有三個動作
猜 對答案 轉旋鈕
你給他一張照片
他猜這是狗
你告訴他 這是貓
他就把旋鈕轉一點點
讓下次猜貓的機會大一點
一張照片轉一點
一萬張照片就轉一萬次
這跟學術化的小孩很像
小孩指著狗說貓咪
大人說那是狗狗
小孩下次就少錯一點
沒有人在小孩腦袋裡寫規則
規則是被一次一次糾正
慢慢磨出來的
可是這裡有一個難題
只有一層的時候
你知道每個旋鈕該往哪邊轉
跌到很多層以後
最後答錯了
中間那幾層的旋鈕
各自要負多少責任
這個問題不解決
網路就跌不起來
這個問題的答案在
1986年被寫成一篇很有名的論文
作者是David Romer Hart
Joffrey Hinton和Ronald Williams
登在科學期刊Nature上
這個方法叫Back Propagation
中文叫反向傳播
它的意思是
最後答錯了
就從最後一層開始
把錯誤一層一層往回傳
每一個旋鈕都會被告知
你讓答案錯了多少
該往哪個方向轉
每一層都照著
後面傳回來的訊息
調整自己的旋鈕
然後再往前傳
這個想法更早就有人提過
可是這篇論文讓大家看到
它在多層的網絡上真的有用
而且中間那幾層
會自己學出有用的特徵
你還記得那兩個開關一盞燈嗎
一塊子木板隔不開
多疊一層
就像多了一塊可以彎的板子
這題就學得會了
擋住感知器將近20年的那道牆
終於有了門
新方法很快就有人拿去用了
1989年
在美國貝爾實驗室工作的
Jan LeCun
用反向傳播訓練的一個網絡
去認訊封上手寫的郵遞區號
手寫數字
正好是那種說不出來的東西
一個人寫的漆都不一樣
你幫他寫一條規則
說漆長什麼樣子
而QN的網絡還加了一個設計
讓他像眼睛一樣
先看小小一塊
找出筆畫的邊邊角角
再往上組合成整個數字
後來這一類網絡
叫Convolutional Neural Network
中文叫卷積神經網絡
他不只認郵遞區號
1990年代後期
他被放進銀行後臺
去讀支票上手寫的金額
會學的小孩
第一次真的去上班了
而且做的正是說明書寫不出來的那件事
照理說
故事應該從這裡一路往上
可是接下來的十幾年
神經網絡反而又冷掉了
1990年代到1000年代
學術界更喜歡其他比較好分析
比較好證明的方法
那些方法在當時的資料量上
成績常常一樣好
甚至更好
而且不用調一大堆旋鈕
神經網絡被很多人看成一門
說不清楚的手藝
你跳了半天
也說不出它為什麼會好
很多研究者後來回憶
那段時間
論文只要寫的神經網路
就很難被接受
整個大環境像冬天
可是冬天裡
還有幾間小溫室亮著燈
Hinton在多倫多
雷昆在紐約
Yoshua Bengio在蒙特羅
還有加拿大的一個研究機構
願意長期資助這些小群人
他們一邊被說過時
一邊繼續把網路疊得更深
後來回頭看
這些小群人守住的
正是今天這些AI的祖先
方法有了人也在
為什麼還要再等
這一段我第一次讀的時候
也想不通
後來才懂
缺的不是更聰明的方法
是兩樣很笨的東西
我們回到學說話的小孩
你想像一個很聰明的小孩
可是他一年只聽得到十句話
而且每聽一句
要想三天才反應得過來
這個小孩再聰明
也學不會說話
當時的神經網絡就是這個小孩
一個缺的是例子
機器學習用的例子
叫data
中文叫資料
那時候大家手上的照片資料
常常只有幾千張幾萬張
網絡轉了半天旋鈕
學不到多少東西
另一個缺的是計算能力
網絡越大
旋鈕越多
每看一個例子要算的次數就越多
當時的電腦訓練一個大網路
要花很久很久
所以神經網路一直看起來不如別的方法
不是他想錯了
是他還沒吃飽
接下來的故事就是這兩個缺口
被兩件跟人工智慧沒什麼關係的事情
一個一個補起來
第一個缺口是被網路補起來的
到了2000年代
網路上已經有數不清的照片
那時在普林斯頓大學的電腦科學家
菲菲利
想做一件當時很多人覺得不值得做的事
他要蓋一個超大的照片資料庫
每一張都有人標上它是什麼
這個資料庫叫ImageNet
問題是誰來標
他的團隊用了
Amazon的一個零工平臺
叫Mechanical Turk
把標照片的工作
切成很小的一份一份
發給全世界很多國家的人來做
最後的成果
是1400多萬張標好的照片
分成兩萬多個類別
從貓狗到各種工具都有
2010年開始
他們每年用其中一部分
辦一場比賽
看誰的城市認照片認得最準
你回頭看
這就是把那個一年
只聽得到十句話的小孩
丟進一座
看不到鏡頭的圖書館
第二個缺口
是被電動玩具補起來的
3D遊戲的畫面
每秒要更新幾十次
每一次都要算出幾百萬個小點的顏色
為了這件事
顯示卡裡有一種晶片
叫GPU
中文叫圖形處理器
它跟一般電腦的主晶片很不一樣
主晶片的核心不多
每一個都很強
擅長一件接一件
做複雜的事
GPU有上千個小核心
每一個只會做
簡單的乘法和加法
可是可以同時一起做
而神經網路學習的時候
要做的剛好就是
大量的乘法和加法
每一個旋鈕都在乘
每一層都在加
比較酷打
讓一般的研究者
也能拿GPU來算遊戲以外的東西
一顆本來為了讓遊戲更好看的晶片
剛好是神經網絡最需要的那種力氣
粒子有了 力氣也有了
就差有人把三樣東西放在一起
舊的方法 新的粒子和新的力氣
把三樣東西放在一起的
是Hinton在多倫多大學的兩個學生
Alex Krzyzewski和Ilya Satskever
2012年
他們做了一個很深的卷積神經網絡
後來大家叫他AlexNet
訓練他用的
是兩張打電動用的顯示卡
就放在Krzewski父母家裡
他的臥室
跑了大約一個星期
那年的ImageNet比賽規則是這樣的
程式看一張照片
可以猜五個答案
五個裡面都沒有正確答案才算錯
第二名大約錯了26%
AlexNet只錯了15%
他一次拉開了10個百分點以上
這不是小贏
是整個領域的人都要停下來看的差距
Ryukyun後來形容
這是電腦視覺歷史上
一個毫無疑問的轉折點
20幾年前的方法
加上一座照片圖書館
再加上兩張顯示卡
就這樣把門推開了
AlexNet之後
事情變得很快
隔年Google買下了Hinton
這兩個學生剛成立的小公司
語音辨識
照片搜尋翻譯
一個接一個換成了神經網絡
這種很多層的神經網絡
這時候有了一個新名字
叫Deep Learning
中文叫深度學習
深度
說的就是陳述很多
你把這一段跟前面放在一起
看會發現一件很有意思的事
AlexNet用的方法
幾乎都是舊的
會學的神經元
是Rosenblatt的想法
反向傳播
是1986年的論文
先看一小塊再組合
是Common早就在做的事
真正新的只有資料多了很多
計算也快了很多
2018年
Hinton、Kang和Bengio
一起拿到電腦科學最高的獎
圖靈獎
這個獎的名字
就來自那個
問機器會不會思考的Turing
冬天裡那幾間小溫室
這時候整片溶雪
我們再停一下
把第二部分收起來
這一部分的問題是
既然智慧寫不完
讓機器自己從粒子學
怎麼講
答案是可以
可是要等
方法早在1986年就有了
反向傳播
讓一層一層的網絡
知道自己錯在哪裡
沒過幾年
他就已經在讀信封跟支票
可是接下來十幾年
他一直贏不了別的方法
因為那個小孩一年只聽得到十句話
而且想得很慢
直到網路給了他一座
看不到鏡頭的照片
圖書館打電動的晶片給了他力氣
他才一口氣把門推開
沒跟上的話
記住這句
方法二十幾年前就有了
缺的是粒子跟計算能力
這個答案會把我們帶到下一個問題
如果粒子跟計算能力就是關鍵
那一直加上去他能走多遠
還有一件事
照片要人一張一張標
標不完
如果機器能自己產生粒子呢
機器自己產生粒子
最早在一個棋盤上做到了
威奇的棋盤比西洋棋大得多
可能那下法多到Deep Blue
那種一步一步算的辦法
根本很不通
而且下圍棋的高手
也常常說不出來
為什麼這一步好
只能說這裡的形狀比較漂亮
這又是一個說不出來的東西
Google棋下的DeepMind
做了一個程式
叫AlphaGo
他先看大量人類高手的棋譜
學人會怎麼下
然後他開始自己跟自己下
下了幾百萬盤
每一盤下完
贏的那一方做過的選擇
就被鼓勵
輸的那一方就被調低
這種學法叫reinforcement learning
中文叫強化學習
它不需要有人告訴他每一步
只需要知道最後是贏是輸
這是解決了上一部分
最後那個問題
例子不用人標
機器跟自己下一盤
就多一盤例子
2016年3月
AlphaGo在首爾
跟世界頂尖騎士Lysetto
下了五盤
五盤裡的第二盤
發生了一件
讓整個圍棋界安靜下來的事
第37首
AlphaGo下了一步
有職業騎士一開始以為是失誤
後來分析
一個人類騎手會下出這一步的機會
大約只有萬分之一
可是這一步
後來被很多騎士認為是一步妙手
這是一個很重要的時刻
他不是在模仿人
他從自己跟自己下的幾百萬盤裡
學到了一個人類下了幾千年都很少走的想法
第四盤
李賽魯也用一部同樣出人意料的題
拿下了唯一的一盤
隔年
Deep Mind又做了一個新版本
這一次連人類的旗譜都不看
從零開始自己下
三天之後就贏過了舊版
你把這幾件事放在一起
就會看到這一部分的主角
不再只是人給的例子
而是機器自己產生的例子
可是圍棋有一個很大的好處
輸贏很清楚
人類的語言沒有這種計分版
語言難在哪裡
你讀一句話
要理解其中一個詞
常常要看很前面的另一個詞
例如
我把獎盃放進行李箱
可是它太大了
放不進去
這裡的它指的是獎盃
你把太大改成太小
它就變成行李箱
一個字的差別
要回頭看整句才知道
在2017年以前
處理語言的神經網絡
大多是一個詞一個詞往後讀
讀到後面
前面的東西就慢慢模糊了
就像學說話的小孩
聽一段很長的話
聽到最後
忘了開頭在講誰
而且他一定要讀完上一個詞
才能讀下一個
沒辦法同時讀
這點很麻煩
因為我們在上一部分才看到
GPU厲害的地方
就是上千個核心同時做事
一個只能排隊慢慢讀的方法
等於讓GPU大部分的核心
都在旁邊等
所以語言卡住的地方
一半是記性
一半是吃不到計算能力
2017年
Google的八位研究者發表了一篇論文
標題很直接
叫Attention is all you need
意思是你只需要注意力
他們提出的架構叫Transformer
它的核心是一個動作
叫Attention
中文叫注意力
它的意思是一句話裡的每一個詞
同時去看其他所有的詞
自己決定哪幾個跟我最有關係
剛剛那句話裡
它這個詞會去看獎盃
看行李箱
看太大
然後把最多的注意力放在獎盃上
這一次
也不用一個一個排隊讀了
所有的詞同時看彼此
這正好是GPU最擅長的那種
同時做事
記性的問題
跟吃不到計算能力的問題
一次解決
這篇論文當時是為了翻譯寫的
後來幾乎所有的大型語言模型都建在這個架構上
有了Transformer
還要回答一個問題
例子從哪裡來
照片要人標
語言要誰來標
答案出奇的簡單
不用標
你拿任何一段人寫的文字把下一個字遮起來
叫機器猜
猜對了很好
猜錯了就把旋鈕轉一點點
答案就在原文裡
不需要任何人去對
這種學法叫Pretraining
中文叫預訓練
2018年
OpenAI
用這個方法做出第一代GPT
G是生成 P是預訓練
T就是Transformer
這一招的厲害之處在於
例子突然變成無限多
網路上每一篇文章
每一本數位化的書
每一段程式碼
都是現成的例子
我們回到學說話的小孩
以前他一年只聽得到死句話
現在他可以把一整座圖書館
從頭到尾偷聽一遍
而且為了猜準下一個字
他不得不學會很多東西
文法 事實 甚至一點推理
例如一本推理小說
要猜準最後一頁兇手的名字
得先看懂前面整本書
接下來幾年
大家發現一件很意外的事
這種模型好像越大越好
而且好得很有規律
2020年1月
OpenAI的Jerry Kaplan
和同事發表了一篇論文
講的是Scaling Laws
中文叫規模定律
他們發現
模型的旋鈕越多
讀的資料越多
用的計算能力越多
猜錯的程度
就照著一個很穩定的規律往下降
而且這個規律在很大的範圍裡都成立
說白一點
你幾乎可以事先算出
多花多少錢
能換到多好的模型
同一年
OpenAI發表了GPT-3
它有1751個旋鈕
是之前同類模型的十倍以上
它出現了一個新本事
你在問題前面給它幾個例子
它就能照著做一個
它從來沒被專門訓練過的新任務
這一課第二部分的那個答案
被推到了極端
如果缺的是例子跟計算能力
那就把它們加到前所未有的大
可是一個讀過整座圖書館的模型
並不等於一個好幫手
你問它一個問題
它可能不回答
反而接著寫出三個類似的問題
因為在網路上
問題後面常常接著更多問題
他學會的是接話
不是幫忙
我們回到學說話的小孩
一個偷聽了整座圖書館的小孩
懂很多
可是還不知道別人問他話的時候
該怎麼好好回答
這時候需要大人來教
2022年初
OpenAI發表了一篇論文
做的就是這件事
他們先請人示範好的回答
再讓模型對同一個問題
寫出好幾個答案
請人排名哪一個比較好
模型就往比較好的方向轉旋鈕
這個方法叫
這個方法叫 Reinforcement Learning from Human Feedback
中文叫人類回饋強化學習
這是AlphaGo那一招的變形
只是記分板從輸贏換成了人的喜好
論文裡有一個很有意思的結果
一個小了一百多倍的模型
經過這樣教過以後人反而比較喜歡他的回答
論文也寫得很直接
把語言模型變大
不會自然讓他更懂使用者想要什麼
2022年11月30日
OpenAir把這樣教過的模型
放上一個聊天網頁
當作研究預覽
名字叫ChatGPT
他的介面簡單到不能再簡單
一個輸入框
你打字
他回話
後面的事你大概記得
你請他寫一封信
他寫
你請他解釋一段程式
他解釋你隨口問一個問題
他像一個很有耐心的人一樣回答你
根據瑞士銀行UBS分析師的估計
他推出兩個月
每個月的使用者就達到大約一億人
是當時史上成長最快的消費型應用程式
這是70年來
第一次有這麼多人
同時親手碰到一臺好像聽得懂人話的機器
你回頭看那張1950年的紙
Turing的模仿遊戲
一個人只靠打字
跟看不見的都這樣聊天
這個畫面突然變成了幾億人每天的日常
可是他真的在思考嗎
這個問題其實早就有人上過一次檔
1966年前後
MIT的Joseph Weissenbaum
寫了一個很簡單的聊天程式
叫Eliza
他假裝成心理智商師
做法只是把你說的話
換個說法丟回來問你
你說我最近很難過
他就問你
你為什麼覺得自己很難過
就這樣而已
可是據說
連Weissenbaum自己的秘書
用了一陣子以後
都請他離開房間
讓他跟Eliza單獨說話
Weissenbaum後來寫到
他沒想到
很短地接觸一個很簡單的程式
就能讓正常人產生很強的錯覺
後來大家把這種現象
叫Eliza Effect
中文叫伊莉莎效應
人很容易把它理解
投射到一臺很會接話的機器上
今天的模型當然比Eliza強太多了
他是真的能做很多事
可是這個提醒一直有效 他聽起來懂 不等於他每一次都懂
他說得很有把握 也不等於他是對的
ChatGPT之後
前沿的競賽換了好幾次方向
一個方向是讓模型先想再答
2024年9月
OpenAI推出一個叫O1的模型
他回答之前
會先寫出一長段自己的思考過程再給答案
他是怎麼學會好好想的
就是AlphaGo那一招
強化學習
這一類模型的計分版
常常是數學題
有沒有算對
程式有沒有跑過
你會發現
這一部分的三個工具
自己產生例子
注意力
人的回饋
在這裡全部接在一起了
另一個方向
是讓模型動手
這種能自己動手做事的
AI助理
叫agent
你交代他一件事
他會自己打開檔案
寫程式
執行
看結果
再修改
一連做好幾十步
2026年9月
Anthropic
推出了Color Opus 5.5
它是現在走在前面的
幾個模型之一
大家現在比的
已經是
他能不能一個人
把一整件工作做完
從一臺只會分辨
簡單圖形的感知器
走到這裡
花了將近70年
我們回到整集的問題
這次卡住的是什麼
答案跟前兩次不一樣
最先碰到的
是他會很有自信的講錯
這叫hallucination
中文叫幻覺
他可能編出一篇不存在的論文
連作者和頁數都有模有樣
原因並不神秘
他被訓練去猜最像的下一個字
而最像的答案
不一定是真的答案
另一個卡點
是我們看不太懂他學到了什麼
說明書的時代
每一條規則都是人寫的
錯了可以翻出來看
現在的模型有非常多旋鈕
是他自己賺出來的
哪一個旋鈕記住了什麼
研究的人還在努力看懂
這是一個有點諷刺的結局
我們放棄寫說明書
換來的機器真的會學
代價是
他學會的東西
也變成一本我們讀不太懂的說明書
還有一個比較實際的卡點
前河店
每網上放大一集要的晶片跟電力
就多一大截
那冬天會不會再來
這個問題我沒辦法回答
我只能把前兩次冬天的樣子
擺在你面前
兩次冬天
都有同一個前奏
一邊是很大的承諾
像20年內做到
任何人能做的工作
另一邊是很多錢
壓在同一個方向
然後有一天
有人拿承諾去對賬
今天這兩個前奏都在
有人說幾年之內
機器就會做完大部分的工作
也有很多錢
壓在更大的模型
跟更大的資料中心上
可是也有一件事
跟前兩次不一樣
前兩次冬天來的時候
真的拿得出去用的東西
都只在很窄的一小塊領域裡
今天的模型
已經每天被幾億人拿來寫訊
寫程式查資料
他可能在某些地方被高估
也可能在另一些地方被低估
可是他不是隻活在實驗室裡的東西
比較可能的不是整片結冰
而是春天說出口的話
又一次被拿去對賬
有些兌現了有些沒有
在收尾之前
我想把幾個名字放回去
2024年諾貝爾物理學獎
頒給了John Hopfield和Jeffrey Hinton
理由是他們的基礎發現和發明
讓機器能夠用人工神經網絡學習
Hinton就是那個
1986年寫反向傳播
也在2012年帶著兩個和聲
推開門的人
中間二十幾年他大部分的時間
都在做一件別人覺得過時的事
同一年的諾貝爾化學獎
有一半頒給了DeepMind的
Demis Hassabis和John Jumper
因為他們用AI預測蛋白質的形狀
我們再往回看
Rosenblatt
沒有等到這一天
他的感知器被一本書擋了下來
Turing也沒有等到
他在1954年就過世了
那篇論文最後寫的那個會學的小孩
要再過60年才真的長大
這段歷史裡最常被講的
是那些大膽的預言
可是真正把路走通的
常常是那些在冬天裡
還繼續點著燈的人
我們最後停一下
把第三部分收起來
這一部分的問題是
粒子跟計算能力加上去
它能走多遠
答案是
比幾乎所有人預期的都遠
粒子不用人標了
機器跟自己下棋
或者把整座圖書館的
下一個字一個一個猜
自己就產生了粒子
注意力讓語言吃得到
GPU的計算能力
人的回饋
教他怎麼好好回話
再加上強化學習
他開始會先想
也會動手
可是走得越遠
卡住的東西也換了
以前卡在我們寫不出來
現在卡在他自己學出來的東西
我們看不太懂
他什麼時候會錯
他自己也不一定知道
每根上的話
記住這一句
機器已經學會了很多
我們說不出來的事
現在難得
是弄清楚他到底學會了什麼
我們回到開場那個問題
70年來
每一次大家都說
機器快要會思考了
後來卡住的
到底是什麼
前兩次卡住的都是同一件事
智慧裡最大的一塊
我們自己也說不出來
所以寫不成規則
後來往前走的那一步
是Turing在1950年就寫下的想法
與其寫一個大人
不如做一個會學的小孩
讓他自己從例子裡學
才等到夠多的例子和夠大的力氣
所以這一集的答案是
難的不是把智慧寫進機器
是讓他自己學出來
而今天他真的學出來了
新的問題也跟著來了
我們要怎麼看懂他學到了什麼
至於機器到底會不會思考
Turing
當年把這個問題換成了一個遊戲
今天這個遊戲很多人每天都在玩
問題卻還在
最後問你一個問題
你第一次覺得機器好像真的聽懂
你是在哪一課
留言告訴我
簡史系列還會繼續
下一段歷史我們下一集再走
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見